most entrepreneurs um that we work at
least are not in it to just have a
return
it's not about making money i mean
that's nice but they're doing it because
they want to make a dent in the world
and they
passionately believe about the thing
they're doing you don't make it if
you're not passionate right
it's just too hard
so
what they what one of the things that
keeps them up at night especially when
they start to get a little bigger is
that they're going to lose what is
distinctive and special in the early
days and it's it's the the
organization's gonna get away from them
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're
talking about coaching meet matt oren
the master coach who supports leaders in
fast growing companies scaling into
their potential with long-term
sustainable success
as co-founder of evolution matt's deep
intuition organizational experience and
behavioral science expertise allow him
to design powerful and customized
development solutions for clients he has
worked with organizations like slack
snapchat change.org coursera tile hero
collective health dropbox and radiology
partners
thank you so much for being here before
i even ask you about yourself and your
coaching practice and your career
what does evolution mean to you why did
you decide to name
this organization evolution
well actually comes from my my
co-founder uh who
coined this term evolutionary business
which is that business can be a force
for good in the world
uh and something that could actually
impact the planet and evolve the planet
and we were having conversations and he
was talking about that and i am a big
believer and love the concept of
evolution as a uh as a model for how
growth occurs right one thing happens
and then it's layered on the next and
it's layered on the next and a lot of
times mistakes
and adaptations and difficult moments
lead to the next uh level of development
and i just think like that's such a
great
uh metaphor for how humans grow and and
the in the planet itself grows so so
you're you're talking about business and
and impact and the world and in the same
sentence yeah you know it's
it's a rather new idea where you know we
have we're putting both of these two
things at the same
level
and at the forefront is this something
that that you always knew that you you
wanted to deal with or was this always
sort of like a thesis that you had about
the business world or is this something
that evolved over time
i was actually uh
quite anti-business in my youth and i
read a book called the world is flat
and that led to this odyssey i was in
grad school and conversations with some
of my professors at pepperdine
and i remember you know hearing these
stories about the impact that business
has had there's the one vignette about
how during the tech before the tech
bubble all the fiber had been laid all
over the planet the bubble blew up and
everybody said that was the worst thing
in the world
but there was all this infrastructure
that was built that led to globalization
right and that's a perfect example of
evolution
um
and
you know i read that the dark side of
business confessions of an economic
hitman and you know these other books
and i started to realize that business
is where people spend the most of their
time
and businesses are eclipsing governments
as kind of the most trusted institutions
in the world and just you know as a
leverage point
there's an opportunity for capitalism
itself to evolve to transcend and
include right so it's still the same
framework but it acknowledges that it's
in relationships with all these other
stakeholders that it doesn't most
businesses don't think about most
businesses think about you know their
shareholders they're bored or whatever
but you know you have community of the
planet itself you have underrepresented
people you have the employees there's
all these other people just like a
community that a business is in
relationship with and you don't
compromise
your
uh the normal business metrics like
revenues by optimizing for those things
too i just think there's actually a
responsibility to do those things and
they all work together in some ways
this is probably another podcast by the
way but i'm happy to talk about it as
well
tell me a little bit about evolution and
coaching for
extraordinary entrepreneurs leaders and
teams and organizations
that specifically care deeply about
changing the world well so you're you
know working with these entrepreneurs
and sort of helping them
and acting as a catalyst what does that
look like
well yeah i mean the the what i just
kind of frame is this macro level
philosophical view but we are
fundamentally a coaching firm executive
coaching firm for venture-backed
companies
arguably i come sometimes chuckle when i
say this they're the the kind of premier
coaching firm in silicon valley
uh you know we've got 35 full-time
partners 150
clients
our biggest clients are twitter slack
glassdoor
all the way down to early seat stage
companies
uh we specialize primarily like our
sweet spot and our early product market
fit was venture-backed kind of b and c
stage growth stage companies
we are uh we joke the house that slack
built they're still our largest client
we started working them when they were
about a hundred people so a lot of my
stories are about the evolution of slack
and seeing how well they did it
um and you know we probably coached 400
people there
yeah
you know over the years yeah and and so
you know we love our work we love our
clients you know we're very humble in
that sense that you know we support
leaders
that are at these growth inflection
points you know and we tend to use the
venture rounds just as an arbitrary
marker because you can kind of peg
company size uh reach you know all that
with the venture round and so there's
dynamics that really occur at each round
and at each round there are like
leadership and cultural challenges
gauntlets if you will that these leaders
are going through
and it's intense and it's fast and so
having a coach that's there to
hold the mirror up around the decisions
that you have uh and give a you know
some guidance really you know something
that a lot of people find value in we
certainly enjoy uh the ride as well on
our learning with our clients so
amazing and so if we're looking
specifically you know at the
organizations that worked with the slack
perhaps you know what are some what are
some things that you've learned or that
you've you know seen with the leadership
that they've done that that can be taken
and can be learned by other early stage
entrepreneurs along their way things
that are you know relevant to to this
idea of good leadership and business
that it is at the end going to make a
positive impact right well if you take
the lens um that says at a certain point
a leader has to care as much about the
org as they do about the product like
they need to have the same level of
craftsmanship for the business itself
and that is a wholesale
operating system change right because
you're just spending time in the product
and all of a sudden there's this
distance
and even at you know 20 and 30 people
there's people doing things that you
can't see me some people are being hired
that you didn't hire yourself
uh and you know at that point you really
have to create and think about you know
that jeff bezos word mechanisms
so the best of what you created
reinforces itself without you in the
room right and if you think about
cynically culture as a control mechanism
it's a way to
create coherence in what you're kind of
creating
and
you know what i give a lot of credit to
the the slack folks because they had
really been through the ringer at flickr
um right you can hear the story and they
had run you know they built flickr they
sold it to yahoo they went through that
experience earlier in their career and
they said we're gonna go back and start
building games
and then everybody knows kind of the
evolution that happened from from glitch
to slack
and stuart and the team at the time were
like they knew they knew that the
trappings of what happens and so you
know stewart is a really intentional guy
and he said we're going to do this
different
and you know right from the kind of that
those inflection points those growth
inflection points
you know it
all credit to them right they were the
ones doing the work but we were brought
in to really support them right which is
in itself a metaphor and they built a
really incredible thoughtful culture
at all aspects of the organization from
marketing to their communications if you
remember the release notes in the app
store were written in a very distinctive
slacky way
uh
the the metaphors and the maxims and the
principles of like why they didn't
provide food for dinner or
why they didn't have like foosball
tables or
how they gave feedback or how they
articulated their values that were
different or how they thought about
product and what that meant about
marketing all of those things there was
like a real design coherence
so this idea of scale without losing
your soul yeah something that
particularly caught my eye
you know as you're working with
companies like slack and snap how how do
you
think of yourself as you know as
evolution
and working with the leadership and and
scaling the organization without losing
the organization's soul
yeah so
most entrepreneurs
um that we work at least are not in it
to just have a return
it's not about making money i mean
that's nice but they're doing it because
they want to make a dent in the world
and they
passionately believe about the thing
they're doing you don't make it if
you're not passionate right
it's just too hard
so
what they one of the things that keeps
them up at night especially when they
start to go bigger is that they're gonna
lose what is distinctive and special in
the early days and it's it's the the
organization's gonna get away from them
and so
what we believe is that i mean sorry if
this is i'm a coach so what do you
expect every organization has in essence
a soul right when it's born when it's
founded we call it its essence um you
can read about it there's a book called
identity's destiny that talks a little
bit about a guy named larry ackerman and
so we believe that through storytelling
you can
you know undergo a process pretty early
in the company to uncover
what the positive core is and every
company just like every tribe of humans
is slightly different there's slightly
different design principles slightly
different you know product ideas
slightly different values
overlap but the distinctiveness matters
and once you define that right you you
really get clear on that essence or that
core
you can build mechanisms in terms of
processes everything from like the
classics like onboarding and feedback
processes to you know accounting systems
and management processes and uh what
metrics you track all those things are
mechanisms that reinforce this essence
as it gets bigger
and then you see companies that have
done it really well that have gotten to
scale and still have who they are intact
and those companies tend to be alumni
farms the google's
baxter
i worked at a place called davida
there's a famous stanford case uh
written about it still one of the best
ones i think taught in the business
school that's like these places are
known for their talent not just for
their business success and there's a
distinctiveness in what they've created
and there's 50 000 people plus working
in these companies
so they've retained who they are as
they've scaled
and you know there's a way to do it just
like a product roadmap you can build a
culture roadmap most of these places and
one way or another have right you think
of the netflix culture guide where you
you get a point of view of who you are
and then you build a road map of 18
months of stuff that you want to create
that reinforces that and even at the
early stages a founding team can have
two slides that describe what is
distinctive about who they are and and
just to kind of end it
we think the organizational essence if
you're gonna discover it it's like
externally it's felt as your brand and
internally it's felt as your culture but
it's the same right your brand and your
culture it's the same essence
and if you're going to be an integrity
and coherent they they're basically the
same and they feel the same so
so if we're talking about this could
this idea of culture roadmap you know
i'm looking at seed stage companies and
they're they're laying out their
four-year plan of where they aim to be
in terms of arr and
and and partnerships and then
sales funnels and hires et cetera what
does a culture roadmap look like is that
the same process is it the same figures
that are supposed to be dealing with it
how how do you go about
strategizing through a culture roadmap
yeah
usually the
founding team you know owned by the
co-founders but it could also be the
founding team
sit down and the first like stage of
that process is uncovering like what
makes us unique
what do we stand for
why would somebody work here versus
their what is our essence
uh what do we want to memorialize what's
symbolic what are linguistic paradigms
and metaphors that really stand out for
who we are
and once that's defined and that takes
some time by the way and that in itself
is almost enough right you discover your
essence it looks like values principles
maxims again metaphors archetypes
after that then you know
this is one of the reasons why people
hire us by the way
you start to think about like what
processes do we need to build that we
would normally build an org building but
if we were going to be a little bit more
intentional and thoughtful we could
create them as design principles like
internal communications both systems and
content
uh all of the early hr processes
how and when feedback is given reward
systems
uh how we think about the product itself
um
how we make decisions and what's
prioritized all of these things you can
just you just need to like write them
down and if you think about some of the
things i rattled off you know it takes
some design right if you're even the
early stages of doing performance
management where everybody gets feedback
on a regular basis you know you have to
sit down with a team of people and think
about
how do we want to do this do we want to
do it twice here do we not want to do it
just do it randomly do it once a year
what's the format look like how is it
distinctive here versus there
for example
uh coursera we helped them uh at one
point as they were scaling designed
their performance management system as a
part of their culture roadmap
and they had a piece in there of course
about learning right because you're
coursera like why wouldn't you know that
be a part of that and actually using the
product itself and so there's
distinctiveness in their performance
management that was very coursera like
and so um
office design the way that looks to the
degree people go to offices those are
things internal brand
meetings and how people meet
uh those kind of things and you just
tick them off do maybe once every couple
of months you you figure out another one
to design it's not that complicated it's
not complicated but you do have to have
time and you have to be intentional as
long as you're willing to give the time
be intentional you can do it
it's a lot like uh like it does not need
to be perfect and in fact it's not going
to be it's not the same as being
clinical or precise it's not at all so
is the main pitfall lack of
intentionality then or are there
different pitfalls that that you see
founders doing that are that are
actively going against yeah this this
notion yeah i mean there's the classic
stuff like pro product market fit an
early uh one of the biggest thing that
blows up companies in the early stage is
the co-founder miss alignment and uh
hiring the wrong executive taking money
from the wrong people who aren't aligned
from you
um those are like
absolutely existential threats to
companies right
um
you won't
and i mean this is a whole nother
conversation developmentally at the seed
stage if you don't create your culture
roadmap you're not going to fail
right
but you will later right and you you
certainly won't become you know iconic
and special because it really informs
you around like yeah we've really we've
literally written recruiting filters for
companies where the recruiters are
filtering these questions through these
principles for people
uh you know slack had an example i don't
know if they still do this or not where
they would literally hire engineers who
were kind over engineers that were
intelligent i mean they had to know how
to do their job but they literally hired
people who were kind you talk about
replicating factors in organization
scales to get kind well-adjusted
software engineers it's like that's an
example of having real discipline and
thoughtfulness and using the recruiter
uh filters through that so
you know if you don't do it at seed
stage are you gonna blow up probably not
are you gonna start having trouble when
you go into rapid scale mode when you
raise your a and b maybe
right maybe
so
so this is going going back to a lot of
the biases that we have you know as
people that we we defer things to later
on and we tend to think short term and
not long term and what you're talking
about here is that we we need to get
trained in being intentional from the
early on stages where we're not just
fighting for survival between the city
and series a but if we don't set us our
foundations right at the sea already
then then it could very well be that
we're going to reach some blocks that
are just not going to allow us to to go
yeah i mean when we always say like just
because you know you can make it out of
c that that isn't a good reason not to
do it like take one day right with your
founding team
once a year pre-seed or seed and just
have the conversation and memorialize it
and see how it goes
like use it when you hire the next few
people or
uh you know when you start thinking
about product decisions like bring in
that filter example like
the earlier you can do it the better
um and you can see the seeds of
intentionality in early stage founders
and i just can't emphasize enough there
is a moment
in most great founders
put aside steve jobs and elon musk that
highly idiosyncratic ones but most great
founders where they're like wow i care
about the people and the org in the
business as much as i care about the
product and it's like this
gone goes off and
it's a weird i mean and we're usually
there for that moment right it's like
them in the coach and they're like they
have this moment of awakening and
they're like i i'm behind
evolution come on we're way behind let's
go right and then they then they like
drag us in
like you should have brought us in at
the a or seed but it's all we can help
so
mac thank you so much for the time and
for the insights and taking a lot of the
intentionality with me as i go on my own
journey and
it was really pleasure and fascinating
story and thank you very very much for
everything yeah thanks for having me i
really appreciate it
you